We live in a time of thirst for data.
Users want more data, and often spend a lot of time searching for it.
As a developer of a great future social networking application, this may look exactly like your business plan.
But unless you create network requests in the right way,
Your business plan will become a big flop.
My name is Colt McCannless.
It is not known to most developers that each application is a single network
Often involves a set of performance issues for users.
In essence, network performance is about reducing the amount of time
Between when the user wants the data and when the network returns it.
There are a lot of things that affect this variable,
For example, delay in bandwidth, speed of cellular communication,
The small mammals, it seems.
These are typical things that users should know,
And generally understand, when it comes to networking.
But there is also a second set of performance concerns
Developers must pay attention to it, which is more realistic.
For example, the use of cellular broadcast waves to connect to the network
Is primarily responsible for spoiling battery performance in mobile phones
The more data you transmit, the more costs and fees for users.
Note, most of the time, people who use limited bandwidth devices
Do not feel grateful to you for downloading 2 gigabytes of image data
For the application of social media.
But in the end, it's all about two main things
Which developers need to focus on.
First, reduce the time that the broadcast waves remain active.
Second, reduce the size of the data you bring.
Now, reducing the number of applications is in fact a complex equation.
But for reason, you can circulate them to three primary groups.
First things that the user asks you to do. Such as, update now.
Second, the things the server needs to let you know, such as a response
Or inform you that new social data is available.
Thirdly, things that must be loaded periodically,
Such as downloading analytics and searching for the location of any device,
Or anything else interesting.
Now, the second and third categories are the main candidates for improvement.
For example, you should never under any circumstances query the server regularly for updates.
You basically waste bandwidth and battery
To tell you the server that nothing has changed
Instead, it is better to take advantage of other services like Google Cloud Email,
Which will allow the server to flag the app when there is new content.
This will reduce the battery consumption of the phone
As well as reducing the total number of server responses
Which you should worry about.
For cases where the use of the cathode is not possible,
It is extremely important to limit the frequency of such requests.
For example, instead of querying the server every five seconds to request data,
You can try using the Undo style
To reduce the number of applications and to obtain the same results.
Instead of leaving your orders organized over time,
Try to group them together, so that they are executed in short batches
In order to improve the active cellular transmission waves,
Which of course, will reduce waste battery.
You can even consider pre-fetching your data so you can reduce the need
To make future requests for what you can do now.
Now, organizing all these improvements together is a quick way
To reduce the total number of applications,
Which will miracles in terms of battery life and costs to users.
The good news is that you can update your app to take these patterns
Without having to write a huge amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is an API of Google Play services,
Which helps you schedule tasks for the network and do the assembly for you.
This greatly simplifies the implementation of common patterns,
Such as waiting for network connection, retry network, accelerated decline,
Basically all the good things you need are a handy and simple API.
Now, of course, is the second important goal that performance targets
Is to limit the size of the data in your order,
These problems, no matter how complicated they are, are my favorite.
Let's see if we can get all this into one chip, do we start?
First, watch the CompressorHead video series
So that you can understand more about data compression in general
And the algorithms that make up this science.
Then make sure that you take the time to read my article about image compression
Then continue to be strict in terms of the quality and format of the images you send to the servers.
Remember, the smaller they are the better.
Oh, and if you are a game developer, check out the topic of "
Or from fast-paced image formats to get better results for an ideal structure.
Once you have completed this, count and check the theme "GZip is not enough"
For a better understanding of compression without loss of textual data.
There is an article about it too.
That follows, of course, a clear look
The number of times you send XML and JSON packets,
Which we hope to frustrate you, you have to realize that you should not send raw text data,
Instead, you should take advantage of Protobufs or FlatBuffers formats,
Which I have a video about too.
I talk a lot about pressure.
However, if you have ever wondered how your application uses the network well or badly,
Make sure you spend a lot of time getting familiar enough
About the networking tool within Android Studio.
You'll see how many times your orders were submitted, the size of those requests,
How long it takes to complete the return trip.
Basically, if something is wrong, this tool is the first step to tracking the error.
But as we all know, this is just the beginning.
For a more in-depth discussion of any of the topics you've put forward,
Check out the rest of the resources of Android performance patterns
And do not forget that there are a lot of developers out there who solve the same performance problems as you.
So visit the Google+ community and ask for advice when you're having trouble.
However, keep calm, write your code, and remember, performance is important.